Happ Manu first of all congratulations I
believe this is your first victory at
the US chess championships uh how you
right now is thank you I'm feeling this
is this was a great game he this all
this line up to like uh Bishop A4 this
was all preparation like I think
whatever he found was the best chance
for black but even after that it's kind
of a difficult ending for him to
hold sorry just to reiterate that you
knew Bishop to A4 as the best move in
this particular variation you actually
looked at this
before yes yes I spent a little bit of
time in the opening just to make sure I
don't like mix anything up but yeah I
knew all the stuff I have to say this is
uh this was a very convincing Victory
congratulations did you feel at any
point that you are letting him get back
into the game or you felt in control at
all
times I felt like whatever I did was
good but there was this one very
critical moment after Bishop E5 like
okay Bishop D4 seems like best chance
yes uh he played Rook ad d8 and now I
was deciding I spent like half an hour
here deciding between Bishop takes E5
and Rook E3 mhm mhm and what another
idea considering was like Bishop takes D
takes E5 Rook takes d8 Rook takes d8
Rook
E3 yes I wasn't like I thought maybe
here black can go B5 and things like I
should be I should still be much better
I wasn't sure whether this was entirely
winning like ab6 cb6 and okay like white
is much better but now you're right
about that right now black has some
chances for sure and you exchange a lot
of Pawns there's not that many
weaknesses definitely the better
alternative the one that you chose Rook
to
E3 yeah Rook E3 I think uh C5 is the
mistake like I was very happy to see C5
like even if I don't have Rook F3 like
if I go Bishop takes E5 and Rook takes
d8 directly like even that position is
much better version of going Bishop
takes E5 Rook d8 first because here I
kind of gain a Tempo
yeah but the other thing was after after
Rook E3 I felt like he had to he had
like basically he can also go Bishop
F4 I wasn't sure like how good it was
but I felt like M should still be much
better because like okay Bishop F4 I had
some ideas like Rook C3 or Rook F3 I
think like Rook C3 C5 Bishop
E3 like maybe it's of course I still
need to calculate a a lot of things here
but this seemed good for way there was
just one very funny position like here
if I go Rook B3 I don't think it works
but like Rook B3 Knight takes C2 Bishop
C3 he has Rook B8 IES let me just catch
up with you Mishra I apologize
um uh sorry I'm going to bring you up on
my
board and uh this was the moment uh tell
me again this moment Rook E3
yes yes I think uh after Rook E3 there
was a very funny variation that if he
goes bishop4 directly instead of C5 yep
Bishop F4 uh like let's say yeah Bishop
F4 like Rook of course it feels very
strange to go Bishop E5 then Bishop for
back but now if I say if I go Rook B3
yep uh Knight takes C2
yeah and now like Bishop C3 was one of
my ideas but now I think after Black
Goes Rook B8 it's kind of Rook B8 I
really I think white just still somehow
be working this but this is very very
funny position it's just Rook on B3
stuck Vish on A4 stuck very amusing on
C3 can't move yeah I mean the Knight on
C2 is trapped but so are your
pieces that's that that that's actually
crazy um Mishra it was one of the most
stunning things about this position and
again I think you played a virtually
Flawless game and really great
congratulations it's an engine R it's an
engine line Mishra but it's hard to
believe that in this position the engine
had proposed for you Bishop takes Pawn
takes F4 and it just had happens by
chance that this bishop on A4 controls
the E8 Square so that after a variation
like takes takes it ends up perfectly
timed and the epon just actually waltzes
up the board did this ever cross your
mind yeah4 unfortunately I didn't see no
I'm just wondering if black goes if
Black Goes Knight C6 uh do I go into the
Rook ending or how do I no you just go
E6 E6 let's say Knight Knight C6 Rook D1
and Rook E8 now E7 yes that's the
variation H King G8 you have like Bishop
B3 or what is Bishop B3 yes E7 King h8
and Bishop
D5 ah amazing Bishop yes that's amazing
geometry 19 1967 rookie won this exactly
you this would have been much a much
better game if I
found no we would have checked you for
Security even worse than than we do
already that's there but okay it would
be nicer to play like this it was
amazing uh line it was engine generated
and I I love the way you played you you
kept control throughout and uh our
congratulations Misha uh 14 years young
you're coming in here I know you're very
very ambitious uh but it's great to have
a good start
too abman I have a question so I know
that when you were playing the US uh
Juniors you really looking forward to
win the event to qualify for this US
championships now you accomplish that
but how do you change your mindset so
you don't see this as a destination to
qualify but actually to uh to succeed in
this
tournament yeah playing this tournament
in itself is like a dream come true like
one the world's best players Fabiano
Dominguez uh leavon ronian like these
guys are the top of the top of the top
and playing against them is it's it's
one of the best opportunities in
classical
yeah here my my strategy is that okay if
it's a draw it's a draw I don't really
care too much about draws but I'll try
my best and we'll see what happens I've
had some similar opposition in uh one
ter in in Sweden I think the name was T
Sigman I like it was filled with gkes uh
Sidler Arjun Ari grandelius and Etc and
I managed to almost TI for first there
so I'm hoping to play up to the same
standard well okay let's I'll play my
best and we'll see what happens wow well
congratulations and good luck in the
rest of the tournament